Okay.
Hey,
what's going on is Bill Byrd is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast,
checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
I am just checking in to see how your week's going.
Now see,
there's a lot of people out there in the podcasting world.
They will do one podcast.
They'll fucking talk to you,
okay?
They'll tell some fucking stories.
They'll do some ad reads for old zip
recruiter.
No.
Say Goodbye.
Yeah.
And you don't hear for them.
Those motherfuckers
for the rest of the God damn week.
See dose those podcasts.
They don't care about you the way I do.
You see,
when we give yourself to Jesus,
okay.
And you understand that we're all brothers and sisters.
I don't look at y'all.
I don't look at yo like just a bunch of listeners,
okay?
I look at you like my brothers and sisters.
Praise Jesus.
Praise Jesus and give me your fucking money and when it rains and the waters
come up,
I ain't letting you in my fucking arena.
Um,
I still love that.
He didn't fucking let anybody in.
Joel Olsteen.
The fucking dude's a gangster,
man.
Fuck you.
You ain't get my blue carpet all wet.
All right.
Jesus won't you to get wet.
He wants you to float out into the Gulf and New Mexico.
Um,
my is it door?
Do I can't get that fucking song on in my head though.
I'm never late.
I had doubt.
You mine as a door Jim.
Fucking some fucking something in a fucking something so close.
So close yet.
So far.
Oh,
I carried your fucking books to school.
That song is so fucking sad.
Yeah,
it's a sad song.
You know what I lived at?
I used to do,
you know something?
I was on a,
I did an episode,
you know,
I got these big shows coming up.
F is for family.
Third season is coming up.
So I'm starting the old um,
promotion tour.
Like right now.
Right now I have 20 minutes between radio phones.
So I figured,
Hey,
you know what I mean?
I'm a guy,
I'm a guy who does a podcast.
Right?
It'd be nice to get 20 minutes to this podcast out of the way.
That's what I'm doing right now.
As you're sitting there going,
wow,
this guy bill checked in on me,
he really cares about me.
I'm actually right now trying to get this out of the way.
Okay?
Okay.
If you want,
full disclosure,
all you people out there,
all you kids out there in the Internet,
you know,
sniff and fucking glue and fucking trying to make water stand up after
you throw him.
Yeah,
I talked about that on Kona.
I just don't understand why everybody finds that so fucking incredible.
You know,
when you really think of the technology out there,
the fact that you can take your own fucking unmanned helicopter and fly it over
some,
over somebody fucking yard and watch some topless chicks,
Tad and her fucking tits,
right?
You can do while watching that in your,
in your fucking room.
Okay.
Beaten your fucking millennial deck.
You know,
all of us teeth,
you would think somebody,
somebody trough flips a fucking water ball up in the air if it stands up
upright.
Everybody runs out of the room.
Like they just saw a fucking,
which is incredible to me.
You know?
That's what's fascinating.
That's just fascinating about entertainment.
You're never,
you have no idea what's going to be a fucking hit and what isn't.
Right?
Just fuck just sitting there.
You're right in the shit.
You shoot the shit,
you put it out there.
You have no fucking idea.
That's why when something is a hit,
Hollywood's like,
oh my God,
they like vampires.
Fucking make 900 of those until they get sick of it.
Then they move onto the next thing.
Like I'm kinda hoping the Superhero Shit is,
has it finally died down.
I was driving down the street the other day by Dubai dual boob and I saw a
billboard by Bata don't book and it said the world has enough superheroes
and it just said venom.
And I was like,
oh my God.
Finally.
Yeah,
they're going to make a movie about one of the bad guys.
Right.
And I can guarantee you if this movie venom is a fucking hit,
next thing you know there's going to be a Lex.
It Luther,
is it Lugar?
Is it Luder Lex the bald guy,
like make you know
whose whole fucking thing
is that?
Like,
he just can't,
he can't stand fucking superman and his full head of hair.
Do you know what I was talking to somebody yet just in order.
This is not even a full head of hair.
It said he has the audacity to have that little curly cue right down the front.
Just mocking.
You know?
I bet Lex had a nice sense of humor at one point before he got all bitter.
You're not bet lexicon,
baby.
Tell a story.
Okay,
I bet Lex had some fucking attributes that made him special,
you know,
but superman got that jet black hair done.
The
okay.
It's so black.
He has blue highlights,
you know,
that is uniform.
Just sets it off,
which brings out his eyes.
What color were his eyes?
That's when you know you're,
you're like to wind to superheros when you know like what color their eyes are.
First Time I opened a comic book and I saw his steel blue eyes,
I was just like,
oh my God,
who is this?
I felt like,
I just want to just in the ocean of ant man's eyes.
What
do you guys think about stem cell research?
I don't understand why this country is okay with one con one company,
you know,
taking over the food supply,
poisoning it,
and then selling the company to another company and everybody just walks away.
Like what they did didn't just happen.
Like there's not fucking eight year olds walking around with full fucking beards
because of all the fucking hormones and shit that they've put in the goddamn
food.
I don't understand why this country is okay with that,
but stem cell research is like,
oh that's the work of the devil.
And then you hear all these fucking stories of people leaving the country.
They go out,
you know,
and they get the stem cell treatment.
Yes.
And they come back to this country.
It's like I thought this guy was a mouth breather and moron.
I mean he just explained the theory of relativity to me.
What the fuck happened?
Well he got stem cell research on his mouth.
They shot it right into the gaping hole that he used to have.
When he would stare at you mouth agape,
when you would flip a bottle over and it would land on upright,
they shot it right into,
it was like a mist.
It was a stem cell mist and all of a sudden his eyes lit up and his mouth
closed.
And now he's a fucking smart guy.
Okay.
No,
I've heard about guitar players like their hands from years of fucking doing the
tap on Solos trying to keep up with Eddie van Halen.
You know,
they fucking get that thing and they come back and they had the hands of a 12
year old.
Okay.
But they,
they keep the experience of being on the road to devastating combination.
You would think something,
you know,
you never,
you,
you know,
it's one of the few times it seems like you're going to have your cake and eat
it.
I mean,
any sort of movie,
if I'm right in that movie script,
that guy as the hands of his 16 year old,
but he loses all of this fucking experience.
Okay.
Uh,
been on the road and all of a sudden he's got to go play a fucking arena and
everybody wants to legend and he's coming out there with his young hands.
I can't remember his songs,
man.
He can't remember his socks.
I'd go,
my fucking hands fixed,
but I can't remember how this song goes.
I fucking don't remember this shit even though I'm the guy that fucking wrote
it.
You know that's a Netflix series right there.
Then you just see what it's like.
The whole meets Eddie van Halen and that'd be fucking the end of every episode
he walks away with this guitar,
you know,
hitchhiking.
Cause he got booed off the stage again because he couldn't remember how it went.
And like every fucking episode he remembers a little more of his catalog,
but he has to practice so much that he's fucking up his hands again and he's
losing money because nobody's showing up.
And now he's not going to have the money to get the stem cell research again.
So of course the woman that fucking spun his blood in the center fuge becomes
his love interest.
Is Anybody writing this down?
This has to happen.
All right.
Do you have my permission to go into Netflix and you pitched this series?
Yeah.
Okay.
You want to see,
you want to see a fucking streaming services,
um,
industry person's eyes fucking light up.
You just walk and go.
I got an idea for a show.
It's like the incredible hulk makes Eddie van Halen and I guarantee you,
you won't even have to get through the pitch and this going to be a fucking,
they're going to slide that check across the table as they play the,
what's that fucking song?
That quick little son they play.
It's almost like when you watch law and order,
Ooh,
well they're going to do that except the Netflix song.
It's really sort of just a note,
right,
isn't it?
They just hit one note.
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
yes,
it's,
it's like,
it's like captain America meets CC Deville.
Just hear me out.
Well,
my only question would be how does he get his hair underneath that mask?
I mean that,
that's,
that's what bumps for me does,
does he slick it down?
Do we see some hair coming out of one of the eye holes?
I think that could be funny.
Do you guys think that could be,
I think that could be funny
though.
I never laid a hand on you ma.
Much motherfucking time.
Do I have before the next phone or I got to do bill.
Were you always funny as a kid?
Tell us what are you find funny today?
Okay.
How do you come up with your material?
Do you have writers?
Do you pull from your real life?
I just did an interview with these guys.
These guys were great,
but in the end they go,
hey,
bill Cosby just got sentenced to 10 to 15 years.
What do you think about that?
Well,
I mean nothing funny.
Are we going to end on this?
Um,
anyways.
Anyways.
I mean that's,
that's right up there with fucking,
uh,
what's his face?
The tight end from the patriot.
You know,
just viewing somebody one way and all of a sudden you just look at them.
The other one,
you're like,
Holy Shit.
And it just fucking affects the whole,
the whole way you look at their work.
Bill,
can you,
can you separate the comedy from the drugging and the raping?
What do we return?
Well,
got some more.
Um,
Bill and you're familiar with the Hindenburg crash and we have audio new audio
just surfaced we find on a 78 speed LP from back then of people on the
Hindenburg screaming as they burned a death.
Uh,
have you heard it yet?
And what are your thoughts?
This,
okay.
Tell the folks what you're going to be joking about.
MMM.
Anyways,
let me,
uh,
I get seven more minutes before I got to hit pause
and move on to this next one.
So anyways,
this stem cell research,
you know,
I got this fucked up shoulder and I've just been,
fixing it old school.
I'm thinking maybe when I go to Eastern Europe.
Okay.
You know,
when I have a day off on my tour,
I'm going to fucking stop in to some local place and like Transylvania or
something,
have my blood spun,
you know,
good evening by one of these fucking guys.
Right.
Is it true that white people in Eastern Europe have flat heads like
Frankenstein?
Do they have like bolts coming out of the side?
Um,
I don't know.
They were behind the fucking iron curtain the whole time I was growing up.
So anyways,
I was talking to somebody about this shit
and [inaudible]
a buddy at guy.
All of a sudden,
this is all the stuff that people are whispering about right now.
Hey,
buddy of mine was in Australia and he got his knees done.
Yeah,
I saw him the other day.
He was jumping higher than a fucking pogo stick.
Right?
And all this shit's getting in my head and I'm going like,
wow.
Stems.
This is fucking incredible.
Doesn't have to do like a baby has to fucking die or something for them to be
able to do it.
Is that what it is?
There's the rest of the world not care about dead babies.
They just look at him like a fucking rusted out car,
you know,
like a parts car cause you're,
you're,
you know,
you just
take it a little baby liver out of it and somehow you put,
I mean you don't bill,
it would probably help if you fucking read up on it.
They actually,
this guy was trying to tell me that through stem cell research they've actually
cured male pattern baldness.
Okay.
But there's so much money in fucking people like myself throwing Rogaine on
their head,
I don't do that shit.
I did it one time and I leave,
felt my heart speeding up.
Now I don't know if that was just the panic of me dealing with the fact that I
was going bald or if it's actually a side effect.
So allegedly my heart rate went up and I,
you know,
if it was,
I can't remember what the fuck was.
This was back in the two thousands
in the year,
2000 pounds in the year 2000
mmm.
It'd be fucking hilarious.
Do you understand how funny it would be if they actually had a cure for fucking
baldness,
but they're just making so much money on the snake oil that they don't let it
come out.
I was joking last night with some buddies of mine going,
do you realize that that would be like,
like Rogaine and all of those guys are kind of like big,
big oil companies.
And then the cure for baldness would be like electric cars or solar.
You know,
and I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think that's the cure for like fucking the environment.
Cause you know God damn well all the raw materials and when you throw out old
solar panels
or the,
your fucking Tesla ends up in the fucking ocean,
that giant fucking battery,
God knows what it's gonna do.
The environment.
But I'll tell you right now that will,
that would be the end to isis.
Okay.
That would be the end of so many of these fucking terrorist groups.
How are they funded?
They're funded with oil money.
Yeah.
You know,
so if both pollute the environment,
but only one of them finances.
The fucking cops were fighting.
Why don't we just switch over?
Okay.
You know,
if every stadium in the NFL could go from natural grass,
most of them I should say over to astro turf and then convert to sort of astro
turf with old rubber tires in there.
If you could watch the NFL,
that billion dollar fucking industry industry changed three times in your
fucking lifetime.
Why is it that we can't switch over to,
so we should be having solar power with full heads of fucking hair,
you know,
and that way we'd be then we,
I think,
I think I just solved the entire Middle East problem in about 90 seconds.
Okay.
You see that?
Do you see what happens
when,
when you're sitting by yourself and there's nobody to question your thoughts or
debate you on any of your points.
Do you see how quickly
you are able to fucking solve problems?
And what do you mean this?
I just got a text message saying he didn't fucking call anybody.
Yeah,
you didn't,
you missed one of your phone is I called.
Okay.
This six 45
and
the fucking
7:00 AM fucking cunts.
I got to put this on speaker here.
Whoa.
Hold on a second.
Hang on a second.
People,
according to my email,
I don't have another phone call until 7:30 AM
period.
You gotta go with a period when,
when you do something like that,
you know,
cause it's polite.
But it's Kurt.
Yeah.
And then there'll be paranoid.
Like is he mad at me?
What is his tone?
And then they back off and then they go,
oh,
I'm sorry,
my mistake.
Even if it was my mistake,
they actually take responsibility.
And that's how
as a person that stands on a stage and performs,
that's how your ego slowly goes out of control,
you know?
And you see examples of it.
It would be like seeing another standup comedian talking about what other
standup comedians should or shouldn't be talking about on stage.
It'd be like if that happened.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
As far as I know.
The next one I'm calling or backs in O'brien,
BA and O'Brien in east long meadow,
Massachusetts.
Okay.
And this is gonna hype.
My show in Springfield on October 4th at the mass mutual.
Okay.
I can't wait to do that Gig,
man.
You got to understand like how many gigs I did in western Massachusetts that did
not go well.
I've told this story.
I went out to exit too.
I got off in Lee,
Massachusetts.
I stood on stage in a restaurant.
I had a dinner roll thrown at me like fucking Nolan Ryan fucking throw it and I
got it missed me.
Jesus Christ sounded like a fucking gunshot when it hit the back of the behind
the wall behind me.
I don't know if it was a stale role or what,
but I'll tell you right now,
I'm still shaking,
you know?
Yes.
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
here's a text message.
See,
I told you the period always works.
Ah,
Shit.
I fucked up.
Got My time zones mixed.
Mixed up.
I'm sorry.
See how that works.
Let me,
I'm gonna read this back to you guys said I called the six 45 and the 7:00 AM
period according to my email.
I don't have another phone call until 7:30 AM period.
And You keep it like that.
No question marks.
No.
Is that cool?
Well,
is it me?
He just fact period.
Fact period.
Send
skip the seven 31 I'll reschedule it.
Oh,
look at this.
I'm going to get to knock out my whole podcast.
Ya
though.
I didn't fuck up my radio tour.
Somebody was waiting for role freckles to fucking call a man.
Talk about his fucking shit.
Jokes that he's going to be telling at the mass mutual fucking center in
Springfield,
Massachusetts.
They got the fucking NBA hall of fame.
Yeah,
no,
I love about that place.
You get to go in there and take fucking you.
In the end.
They got some hoops.
You can shoot a couple of fucking hoops.
Take a three pointer.
You know,
I've been to all of them.
They don't have a batting cage at the baseball hall of fame,
nor should they,
because that's,
that's the purest one.
That is the hardest one to get into.
You know what I mean?
You have a better chance of bang in a fucking supermodel.
Then you do have getting into the fog.
You understand that
they getting into the fucking major league baseball hall of fame
because you know,
you,
you'd go to fucking New York,
you go to La,
you walked down the street,
you'll see one of those supermodels walking down the street looking like a
fucking giraffe and high heels.
Maybe you say something,
maybe maybe you get,
throw him a line,
maybe go reverse psychology.
You look at their designer bag and just this is that from,
is that,
uh,
I wish I knew line of a cheap line of is something,
something that makes them question themselves,
you know,
not that I've had this experience before,
but I would think that if that is what your job is,
okay.
Every fucking day you just looking in the mirror knowing you're another day
older.
Oh Geez,
what am I talking about?
That's the business that I'm in.
You know what I mean?
These people that come out here and they base it on their looks or get shit
because of their looks.
You know,
everybody's like,
they always looked at him,
you know,
and they love him and then eventually they,
they fucking,
they don't like him anymore cause they're good looking and their beauty reminds
them of the horror that they see every time they brush their own teeth.
Yeah.
You walk into the bathroom.
Actually had somebody install a dimmer.
You have the light on like 30%.
You just come walking in,
right.
And just start a memory.
You know,
you're looking down cause you just don't want to catch,
you don't want to catch what you see in the mirror.
You just look down,
you grab your toothbrush,
you put the toothpaste on it.
And at some point though,
okay,
you have to look up and you have to face you.
It's sometime she don't like what you see.
MMM.
No,
it's a tough fucking game.
You know what's funny about really good looking people like they're the only
people who get called out for aging.
Have you?
Either that or people you went to high school with.
Well,
back to my high school or uni.
Jesus Christ.
Bill Bird looks like he's fucking in pappy on.
MMM,
that'd be on when she has friends for Jose.
A butterfly.
That meal prep meal.
Excuse him,
mom and Moselle.
Eylea
um,
there's a butterfly in the kit.
In the refrigerator.
Why is the butterfly the refrigerator?
This is when you learn French.
This is the kind of shit you learn how to say.
Look Shit.
You would never say if he went to France,
excuse a mom.
Amazon,
Lex,
uh,
Lex pepe on down now.
Frigo a lap.
Ben.
Wait,
wait.
Basically should I fucking throw the thing out?
Cause it's obviously dead
kiss crusade.
Ooh,
Mike,
I'm not going to fucking torture you with my goddamn French.
I already did that to the wonderful people of France who had the fucking decency
to say,
we're not going to accept that poisoned food from your country unless you
fucking label it.
And then the wonderful people of this country,
we're like,
there's no fucking word on afraid.
Once you're in the floor.
Yes,
they talked like the devil and a heavy metal record.
That's how I picture those people work on an rig and foods.
Okay.
We're old.
Ever quit.
Put it in your mouth and eat it.
Well,
we will stop making food.
Um,
I know this is fucking weird.
What do you want from me?
It's like fucking seven in the morning.
I ain't supposed to be up right now.
This is literally like a vampire at fucking getting up at noon to fucking watch
the price is right.
Like I should not be
okay.
Seven 50
vampire watching the price is right.
Come up people.
That's fucking funny.
It's funny to me in the morning.
Hi or higher watching the games.
No.
What a fucking drew Carey retired from the price is right and they hired a
vampire to host it.
Yeah.
You know,
they'd have to start doing the tapings at night.
Good evening.
Welcome to the prices,
right.
Oh my God.
I'm going to fucking pitch that to fucking Hulu.
All right.
This is like a game show meets Bram Stoker's whatever the fucking,
I never watched any of those stupid fucking movies.
The last vampire movie I watched was Brad Pitt.
It fucking,
um,
no,
that's not true.
Okay.
I watched the one where the little girl was the vampire,
her and her and her dad moved into the complex.
Okay.
That was a cool one.
That is true.
I just told,
I just basically caught myself in a lie,
you know?
Do you know,
it's been like a month since I've flown a helicopter and I just keep seeing
these fucking magnet pis,
Bao,
Bao by now.
How would that fucking song goes?
That's what I was songs she can't hum.
Except for the beginning.
Banaynay 80.
Neat.
It goes off.
It goes up the fucking real.
We'll bill.
Maybe if you watched the show a little more.
Um,
you know,
it's fucking weird about that show.
Like,
okay.
Oh boy.
Let me get to the point.
Every time I see that fucking,
that beautiful MD 500
when he's flying that fucking helicopter,
I'm just like,
I'm like,
I'm really like,
I'm watching that fucking show.
And I liked that they went old school with the helicopter,
but I feel like they should've given him a new Ferrari
because that's not one of the classic for,
I was like that for hours,
not worth a
lot of money,
you know?
As far as Ferrari's go,
like you could,
you could pick up one of those fucking for Robbie's.
Let me,
let me know.
Let's that like,
we know that it's fucking,
look at the price of one of those fucking things right now.
What do you say?
They're freckles.
All right.
We're looking up Tom Salix Ferrari.
They,
we're going to see how much it fucking costs.
Magnum,
not condoms.
Magnum p I,
yeah,
do,
do battle.
[inaudible] like,
I can't remember how it goes.
Magnum Pi Ferrari.
I would stay at three Oh eight gts.
All right,
let's look that up.
F E R r a r.
I
what did I just say?
Three Oh
eight GTB and gts.
Okay,
let's see.
Uh,
the fried.
Oh,
you fucking Wikipedia.
Can't
God damn.
Motherfucker.
Why does,
why is it my,
all my fucking defaults go to those assholes.
You know what?
Probably cause you went to it too many times.
Ah,
this douche again.
Okay.
Wikipedia.
The Bald Khan has another question for you.
Tell them I'm not here to like,
hey Belk.
I just see again.
What,
how old Gavin Macleod?
Ah,
fucking 85.
Alright.
Ferrari three Oh eight gts for sale.
Now I imagine the price went up cause magnet pis coming back bowed out out.
I own,
I own amp or nothing.
Okay.
All right.
Three Oh eight gts for sale.
I remember Barry Katz,
I trashed him on his own podcast.
He owned a half the stand ups in the fucking world money and he went out and
bought one of these things.
Yeah.
At 54,000.
It's still a lot of money.
79,000.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
that one.
Joy Bay.
Huh?
I don't know why I said her name.
I just want,
I just wanted to say her name.
She's one of the coolest fucking people I've met in this business by the way.
Don't sleep on fucking joy Behar.
I did an episode with of crashing with her and she was fucking hilarious.
All right.
Uh,
64,
five.
What about the ones from the 80s 83 is 79,000.
1980 70,000.
Jesus,
you know something.
When people buy Ferrari's in the supercars,
everyone thinks it's a giant fucking waste of money,
but you know they really retain their value.
There's no way that fucking car costs that.
Ma,
I'm going to go out on a limb and say it didn't cost that amount of money when
you first bought it.
It actually appreciated in value
after what these bankers did,
this fucking country in 2008 this people in houses that are never going to
appreciate value as far as what?
They still own it on it.
People,
I'm telling you right now,
he wanted to turn around your financial fucking situation.
Okay?
You sell your house,
you buy a Ferrari fucking g,
t s and you live in that mother fucker.
Eventually that car's going to be worth more money.
Then you owe for your house.
Well,
you sold the fucking thing,
but you still owe more than what it was worth.
So you know what I'm saying?
There's a balance there that needs to be dealt with.
You don't drive it anywhere.
Okay?
You just fucking do alternate side,
weak fucking parking and you just sit in it to a one day.
That fucking car is worth more than once you own your house plus a Turkey
Sandwich,
then you sell it.
Then you walk down the street,
you get yourself a Turkey sandwich and you like,
you know what?
That's delicious.
And now I have nothing.
MMM.
What's that country where bankers get put to death if they do shit like these
fucking constant in this country,
you know?
Is it Singapore?
Is it somewhere in Malaysia?
It's a Thailand,
Laos,
Vietnam,
India,
China,
Mongolia,
Japan,
Guam,
um,
DG.
We honeymooned in Fiji we had a hot,
it was so amazing.
You look through the floor,
you could see the fucking ocean.
It's one of those things,
like if I was a woman and my husband took me
to one of those fucking huts that sits over the ocean,
like I wouldn't be able to sleep comfortably because I feel like if your
husband's ever going to fucking kill you,
it's either going to be 20 years into your marriage or on the honeymoon.
So you got to get past that first hiccup and just knowing,
okay,
that this dude could kill you and then just drop you right through the fucking
floor.
You know?
Any other thing,
ladies,
if I can give you any advice,
like you want to be in a hotel,
so if he drops through the floor,
you land in somebody else's room in at least he's going to get caught,
you know?
Yeah.
Don't go to that fucking hut that's on stilts above the Goddamn Ocean.
Don't take a cruise,
don't go scuba diving.
These are all fucking stories you hear.
I Dunno if they're true.
It's just people you know,
say them and then I repeat them without ever doing any research.
There was that woman,
she went on a fucking honeymoon and so much she got eaten by a shark or fucking
like the guy shut off the oxygen tank.
It was on the fucking honeymoon.
This is why they should have a fucking class in high school teaching people how
to get out of a relationship.
Do you understand this person was in a fucking relationship with somebody that
they did not want to fucking be with and all they had to do is just sit down and
say,
listen,
we have to talk.
I'm not happy.
I love you,
but I don't love you in a way that makes me want to marry you.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
And that's all you have to say.
How long did that take to say that she's going to cry?
Be Shocked.
Possibly throw something at you,
call you in the face,
called the police and said that you attacked her and then you go to fucking
jail.
Right.
Okay.
Fucking with you.
But I'm just saying,
yeah,
it's literally a fucking fifth.
It's a 15 second statement.
Yeah,
I know.
It's awkward.
You don't want to fucking do it,
but just memorize it.
Just sit down and say it so you're not standing there at a fucking wedding
going,
what the fuck am I doing?
And just avoiding confrontation and standing there going with this ring I wear.
Do you flop,
sweated fucking jackass.
Agree to take this woman who's fucking ecstatic because she doesn't know what
you're feeling and you're sitting there,
your head's going.
Don't say it.
[inaudible] you go,
I do do do,
do.
And then you're like,
now how the fuck do I get out of this?
Now I'm going to get divorced one day maybe.
And that's a combination at the fucking divorce laws is so fucking brutal.
And then all these strong women are out there getting fucking ridiculous amounts
of money for child support.
He saw the whole fucking thing.
So do you realize rather than just simply breaking up with the person,
this fucking guy goes,
I know
we're going to get certified to scuba dive.
Okay,
we're going to go underneath the ocean.
I'm going to shut off for fucking tank and went to work.
This whole fucking story,
having never committed any sort of major crime.
I think I'm going to sit across from the cops,
okay.
And be able to hold it together and get away with fucking,
I'm going to break the fifth fucking commandment and for the rest of my fucking
life,
I'm never going to enjoy one day knowing,
okay.
That I took another life.
Do you know one time that I know I'm off the rails here?
I,
you know,
one time I fucking,
there was this rapper from Africa and he was one of those boys,
soldiers over there that fucking gets commandeered at like nine and kills more
people than fucking Rambo by the time he's 11.
Um,
he was talking when his album came out,
he was talking about,
uh,
all these rappers in America that would brag about killing somebody and he was
fucking,
he said one of the coldest things,
but like so true where he was just like basically saying they were full of Shit.
He said,
when you kill somebody,
you don't brag about it.
It haunts you.
Okay.
And I was like,
oh my God,
I got to listen to this fucking guy's album.
Okay.
You know?
I mean,
how do you not fucking listen to that guy?
Okay.
I mean,
if you're listening to this shit,
I know what you're saying right now,
but what is the guy's name?
I don't remember,
but I don't think there's a lot of fucking boy soldiers that turned MCS out
there,
you know?
All right.
Have I talked enough?
I have to do a little bit of advertising here.
People.
I don't have the advertising yet because I'm so ahead of the fucking game,
you know?
I feel that I did.
I did the upon,
I just did the podcasting equivalent of doing the dishes before you go to bed.
I'm tell you what,
if you suffer from fucking depression,
not clinical,
but just fucking low take,
it's going to work out for me,
man.
If that's what your fucking brain says to you and you want to start turning it
around,
I'll tell you something.
Nothing lifts your spirits.
Yeah.
Like fucking,
yeah.
Common downstairs in the morning and all the dishes had done a walking across
your fucking apartment,
or maybe you're in a fucking studio.
Okay.
And the sinks right next to your futon.
Hey,
I've been there,
you know,
and that Faucet keeps fucking tripping and you can't get it to shut it off,
shut off seats,
put a towel in there and you just lay there thinking that you solved the problem
and then eventually the towel gets too wet.
Yeah.
And rather than hearing the sound of the water hitting that fucking stainless
steel,
it then becomes the fucking towel and you just hear
Yup.
And then you start thinking,
maybe I could get certified,
just go scuba diving with my landlord
rather than calling a plumber.
All right.
Um,
yeah.
That in making,
making the bed,
make the bed before you go to work,
come home.
You know,
some,
I don't know what it is.
You get into a bed that's made,
it's,
it's more fucking comfortable.
The sheets are all fucked up and everything.
He just,
it's just,
it's awful.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's like if you grab a newspaper off the newspaper stand and nobody's read it,
it just,
uh,
it's just CRISPR.
The words jump out at you.
But if you pick one up,
you know,
at the bus station,
pull it off as some bumps fucking face with sleeping,
right.
It just doesn't seem the same.
And you know what,
that's one to grow on.
All right.
Um,
I'm gonna shut this off and then I'll fucking splice everything together and
you'll,
you'll never know the difference.
All right?
This is weird,
you know,
I guess it's just pretend like I already have the advertising.
All right.
People are,
we do a couple of advertising reads here.
Hey,
what's going on?
All right.
It's bill burr.
I'm back.
I always have to say,
hey,
what's going on when I'm starting,
I'm trying to get the fucking copy here for the,
uh,
the goddamn reads.
And of course it's not working out.
Why would it work out?
Why would anything I totally fucked up with my goddamn computer.
The thing was filling up.
It told me it was going to be filled up.
I fucking ignored it.
Now it's now it's completely fucking full and I keep trying to put them onto
these little fucking lightening sticks,
whatever the fuck he call them.
It used to stick in the Saudi computer.
First one worked fine,
got all the pictures and video on it.
Second one.
I go fuck yourself bill.
Now I got to play a game.
Now I only have it on one of these fucking sticks and they are called lightening
sticks in my world.
All right,
Amigo.
Okay.
Uh,
no.
That's as ami go.
Okay.
Like you know it's funny.
Back in the day you could read Lord and Taylor,
Jordan Marsh.
Now everybody's got to be so God damn cool.
Oh,
am I a g o Oh my,
go.
Oh me go.
Oh me,
go.
All me go.
A revolutionary toilet seat replacement for your fork and age.
Are you anal about cleanliness in the bathroom?
Have you really ever thought about wiping with toilet paper?
Like really thought about it.
Please click for a demonstration in details.
Yeah,
I'm going to skip that.
A wash
washing you in all the right places.
All this is the,
all that the thing here.
So it's like a bad day.
Is that what we're talking about?
Yeah.
All right.
Let me see.
Okay.
They got this smiling guy meet.
Oh,
me go.
go all my go.
All right.
Let's listen to this.
You see this.
This is the past,
and frankly that's toilet paper.
Let me introduce you to the future.
Is Omega a new high tech toilets and it changes everything.
It's going to spray water up your ass.
First thing's first installation,
handyman.
But it's fast and easy.
Just take off.
He's no handy man.
And there's a woman fucking doing it.
Yeah,
there she is.
Water.
Plug it in.
She's ready to go.
I can't tell if that's sexist or empowering.
I mean,
he didn't know how to do what she did,
but she was on her knees in the bathroom.
The first thing I notice is that the seat.
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
I'm fucking long.
Does it have to be all right?
Evidently it sprays water up your ass.
And that's the way of the future.
All right.
Adjust the water temperature,
the position in case it's fucking,
it's treating your taint like it wants equal rights.
Uh,
water,
water temperature,
position pressure with movement with,
yeah.
I guess there are different size assholes out there.
Features,
heated seat.
I'll fuck goodness sake.
Are you serious?
You see I'm trying to learn how to not to not curse in front of a my daughter
for goodness sakes.
J C F and g d m f C.
Um,
alright.
A heated seat.
A nightlight soft closing air dry,
remote controlled.
Deodorizer is there not enough global warming that we got to turn this thing?
I mean how much,
what is the carbon footprint and this fucking thing.
Say Goodbye to toilet paper.
Save trees.
You saving.
Why the fuck are you saving water?
Maybe I'm save water and electricity by having a heated seat and water spraying
up your ass as opposed to a cold seat with toilet paper.
You U s alone uses 36 million rolls of toilet paper in one day.
Clean and safe.
Automatic self cleaning on demand.
Silver Ini sterilize.
Install yourself and just 20 minutes.
Get a hundred dollars off your,
your order when you go to all my omi goal dog.
All my go.
Amigo,
my Amigo Dotcom.
Slash.
Bird.
That's O.
M.
I g.
O.
Go to Omi.
Go Meiomi go.com my homie.
Oh go.
Uh,
my Meiomi go.com/bird.
He got $100 off the future.
Seems Weird at first.
Let it be weird.
All right.
Maybe I'm behind the Times somehow.
That's more environmentally friendly.
All right.
Oh look,
look who it is.
It's not us.
It's him.
A,
here's a problem.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35.
Hey,
that's a sensitive subject with me.
Thing is when you start to notice hair loss,
it's too late.
Um,
all right,
well I guess I don't need to pay attention for the rest of this.
It's easier to keep the hair you have then to replace the hair.
You've lost all this is fucking genius.
We already got the ball guys dumping shit on their head.
Let's get people have full heads of hair to get paranoid.
I love this.
Uh,
is that hairline?
Oh,
he's starting to recede.
Started moving backward.
Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
I thought you just said if it,
you're already losing your hair.
It's too late.
Some of these kids,
the way they write their copy out,
boy,
I'll tell you why did guys turned a weird solutions or do nothing?
Well,
what the fee.
It's shit.
Nami is,
yeah.
This,
this,
all of this copy shitting all over me.
Uh,
when they can,
they can turn to medicine and science.
I wanted to age naturally and Gotcha.
Uh,
what hymns does is connect with real doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss well known generic equivalents to name brand prescription pricks
prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counter supplements.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to four hymns.com h I m s.com.
What about for her?
Women Have Alopecia sometimes answer a few quick questions.
Doctors were review and can,
can prescribe you.
A product is shipped directly to your door.
Order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 right now while supplies
last.
See websites for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Well,
you could also see the doctor as opposed to this shit.
When you say doctors,
look at it.
How the fuck do I know?
You know?
Go Go to four hymns.com/bird.
That's f o r a H.
I m s.com/barefoot for hymns,
Dotcom.
Slash.
Bar.
Ah,
here we go.
Here we go.
Getting down and dirty on the last one.
My bookie,
everybody.
That's right.
Who's playing tonight?
It's Thursday night football.
I don't know who's playing to be honest with you.
I have no idea.
I knew.
Wait,
I do know.
Okay.
Monday night football is Denver and Kansas City.
Thursday night football
Steelers.
Tampa Bay was Monday.
I don't even know.
All I know is I'm watching.
All right.
You know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people by asking me for advice,
ask me what team to bet on two theories.
I fucking know who's going to win,
but you know what?
If he think you're going to,
if gene fucking take,
you know,
you got to check out my bookie.
Remember who you're betting on is just as important as who you're betting with.
Think about it.
Make sense after a while.
That's why I always tell people to bet with my bookie.
Trust me guys,
they're your best bet for this season.
They've been in business for years.
I have great reviews online and their mobile side is easy.
Use My bookie you when they pay,
I mean that fucking simple.
They have in game live betting the most rewarding perks in the business and for
you fantasy guys out there,
oh my God,
he's on my fairness.
The team.
If I could have one wide receiver,
it'd be you.
You can even bet over at the,
over under on how many fantasy points a player will score each game.
My bookie is slammed with new betters and wants to give everyone the best
service possible.
If you're willing to deposit after 7:00 PM eastern time,
they'll give you an additional $25 free play on deposits over $100 joy now and
my bookie will match your deposit dollar for dollar use Promo Code burpee.
You are ours to activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie.
M Y B O.
O.
K,
I.
E.
And don't forget to use Promo Code [inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free play.
And now if you're willing to hold out until after 7:00 PM you can get an extra
$25 free play by using Promo Code B U R R two five it's up to you guys.
But I would wait to after dinner,
I'd take that extra money.
Hey,
you can do it how you want.
You play,
you win,
you get paid.
Yeah,
I fucking love it.
MMM.
How the fuck is adding electricity to a toilet seat?
More Environment and fucking a water fountain up your ass more environmentally.
I mean that,
that,
that right there.
That right there was,
is,
is the reason why I don't invent shit because on paper,
man,
that doesn't make no fucking sense.
All right,
you guys enjoy the music.
There's to be another half hour of a,
um,
a greatest hits Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
Um,
I'm going to be at the La Forum tomorrow night wearing a Larry Bird Jersey.
No,
I wouldn't do that to you.
I thought about it,
but I'm not going to do that.
Why?
Why not make it an enjoyable experience.
I'm going to get the La Forum tomorrow night.
Get your tickets.
You only got one more fucking day.
Come down there.
See?
Oh,
freckles.
All freckles and that big old fucking place.
Um,
and I'm in Denver.
Okay.
With dude.
I called it the pride of Newark,
New Jersey.
Paul Versey,
owner of an absolutely beautiful,
uh,
Toyota Lexus.
Daddy.
Say it.
Lexus by Toyota.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You cuts
pets.
Both.
Okay.
I'm really crying and I just think it's nice that after all these years,
the Emmy's finally stepped up and gave everybody else in a ward.
Um,
Jason's,
my wife was watching that thing last night.
What a fucking shit show.
Hey,
dapper stranger need to live
her in the van with the kids.
Is that right?
I don't know,
man.
I gotta tell you something.
There's no way that it's worse.
It's for someone who is into watching award shows out award show to make them
watch sports.
There's no way that that's a worse experience than someone who watches sports.
Having to sit there and watch a fucking,
the Emmy's,
you know,
I didn't have to sit there.
I kinda had it had to because uh,
you know,
I didn't see my wife and a couple of days and she was like,
I want to hang out with you.
And then we had to sit there and just watch these fucking things.
It just,
ugh.
Okay.
The actress,
it just so God damn dramatic.
Yeah.
Tammy goes to
Sarah.
Awesome.
This is the first Emmy win and six nomination for Sarah Hall.
I had one of those mouth wedding drops and now I can't feel my face.
So this is a problem.
It was because you thought I could that I even dared.
Yeah,
because you believed in me.
I dared to try.
I almost fucking threw up whoever the hell said that because you believed in me.
It's like you're a fucking actor.
It's a killer script.
You what?
You're going to turn it down.
That fucking Oj mini series was,
was unbelievable good.
Turn up the pressure pressure.
You want to turn up the pressure.
I don't believe in me,
but because you did.
I dared,
I dared to try.
Ugh.
Worst things I've ever heard.
You know,
other than when you call up the cable company,
if you learn to do these days,
when you get into that,
talking to a robot lady is one notch lower than that.
I'm not shitting on the actor.
You know what I mean?
They get God because they're like that.
That's why they give the great performances and because I'm a cunt,
that's why I do stand up.
You know what I mean?
So everybody finds the little fucking hole is supposed to crawl into,
oh my God,
there's always,
these are,
these are important stories and they need to be told
Doerries that provoke conversation,
necessary conversation.
And it also creates privilege.
When you take women,
people of Color,
trans people,
Queer people,
and you put them at the center of the story,
these subjects,
instead of the objects,
you change the world.
We found out
just take a shiny thing and leave.
Just give us the keys.
Oh,
oh God.
Because you believed me.
I dared to try.
Um,
I dared to try
the next time my wife compliments me.
I'm going to say that to her because she believed in me.
I dared to try.
These are stories that need to be told.
We're storytellers.
It with us,
without us giving people a voice.
You know what else is great?
You know,
as the Emmys,
I think the Emmy's got scared by all this shit.
The Oscars.
God,
you know,
and what was funny is as many people of color,
that one,
what are the funniest shots all night long was when you know,
if you looked,
if they just would like do a shot behind Jimmy Kimmel and you saw the front row,
it looked like a great mix of everybody.
But when they did the,
the shot was when they'd come back from commercial and you saw the whole crowd.
It was like from the thousandth row up to the third row,
it was all white.
It was like,
it looks like a foreign,
a concert from the back row all the way,
like the third rail.
But if they did it the way they shot it,
they front end loaded like the 15 black people that were there.
They just had them all right in front the juice box.
You would like a juice box.
There you go.
Take the whole thing.
Some Asian people and all that,
but all the way to the back.
I was joking with Nia,
like if you live in New York City,
every once in a while you go into one of those bodegas.
Etsy that deal and drugs.
It just going on at business.
A little corner stores called Bodega's.
Say it with me,
both Degas and it looks like it's fucking stocked with food and you grab that
one can of food and you look and it's like behind that can,
this is just completely empty.
So I did get some laughs while watching it.
Jesus Christ,
the weight of every fucking thing that they say.
It's just unbelieve.
It's just like that inside the actor's studio when that fucking guy just sits
there like I hope you realize the presence of greatness that we are.
You know,
it's just like Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you fucking get pretending to be a fireman.
Relax.
We've arrived at a difficult moment.
Of course,
it was so brave.
It was such a brave performance.
You know what I mean?
There's this fucking people update at the end of building skyscrapers and shit.
Oh,
those guys who go up and they change.
You ever see those things?
Mike,
my palms literally sweat watching these people.
They climb all the way up those towers to change the fucking light.
The little light bulb at the top of the tower at the top of the fucking
building.
So,
so plain can see it at night and they get that part where they unhooked the
safety thing.
Free climbing is more dangerous of course.
But Osha rules do allow for it.
Jesus Christ it putting on 20 pounds and wearing a wig is brave.
What the fuck is that?
Huh?
You can't die acting canyon.
Well,
I guess you can't
that there's ways to die as an actor,
right?
The fake gun on set turns out it's got,
you know,
you put it up to your head is that they'd be fucking bring a helicopter.
People have died on set.
So no disrespect to them.
29 minutes a Yammer inbuilt Jesus fucking Christ.
You know,
some days the podcast is hard.
Other days it's easy.
But I just want to say to everybody who listens
because you dare to download idea to try
[inaudible].
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 27th,
2010 and a and it is still Monday for all you fucking assholes giving me shit
saying I haven't.
You haven't posted a podcast.
What the fuck's going on?
It's still Monday.
It's still Monday morning.
Where I,
where I live.
It's not my fault.
I live,
I live at the end of the street.
You know I live at the end of the fucking street when it comes to the world,
you realize that shit other than Hawaii,
you know,
and maybe a Amelia Earhart's fucking great,
great grandson
or grandson at this point.
Ryan be grandson.
She crashed,
made it to an island.
Fucks him God Damn Aborigine,
right?
Bang.
Solitude ends up having a fucking baby.
Some fucking group of people that we haven't figured out that they lived there
yet so we could exploit them,
destroy their goddamn culture and she put up a fucking best buy.
You know,
maybe,
maybe those are the only people who don't bitch at me.
It is to Monday morning podcast.
It's nine 43 Monday fucking morning.
Okay.
Syriza Monday morning podcast or write or write their epic fail guy who sent me
the email.
Ah,
you want to see an epic fail?
Why don't you look up when
you're shaving next time,
buddy.
All right,
I'm going to fucking mood.
I am in a mood today because my computer sucks.
Server not found.
What does that even mean?
What the F,
How am I offline?
Ah,
Jesus.
Now you guys are going to see what kind of skills I really fucking have
considering I'm not even online right now.
They just took away my,
my little security blanket.
Um,
hey,
somebody sent me a,
a,
an email talking about irony.
Um,
you know,
the Segway,
that little two wheeled thing where you lean forward and it goes forward and
then you lean back and then it stops.
It's something like that.
Evidently it's,
it's,
you know,
it's a,
one of those devices they made because I think that they felt like people
weren't fat enough and if there's any way,
if we could just eliminate all walking.
Uh,
anyways,
this,
the segway owner died,
uh,
after falling off a river cliff riding a segway.
I know it's not a nice thing to do to laugh at someone who dies.
I know that they have family saw him.
Um,
you know,
well,
what the fuck
and just the whole name of its segue.
You know,
the segue brought him from this life into the afterlife.
That was the segue.
Jesus Christ.
I want,
what was he thinking on that fall?
I showed her whoa.
Oh,
and you know,
he was wearing those fucking shoes with the tassels.
You know,
those ones that rich people,
where are those fucking loafers?
You know,
they always wear the loafers without socks and they got their khaki shorts and
some sort of yachting polo shirt.
My buddy who was dressed like that,
he's probably on his cell phone.
Maybe he was texting while he had another one up against his chubby rich cheek
from all those fucking Hams east to eat at that long dining room table.
Hey,
I'm going to take out my segue.
Gulf oil is spin around the fucking river that we bought
and you know,
would be fucking hilarious as if he,
when he went over the cliff,
I bet he had a death grip.
You ever hear of what a death grip is?
Well,
I'm going to tell you,
even without the Internet sometimes,
uh,
when,
when you're,
you're,
when you're in a,
in a situation where you're going to die and I think it involves falling,
your body has what's known as a death grip and it's,
you just hang on so fucking tight.
Like I saw this one time,
it was basically,
there was those two guys flying in a plane.
Two guys flying into a plane,
walk into a bar.
The bartender says,
Hey,
you,
you can't fucking park that in here.
What's the deal?
Two guys a flying this fucking plane,
right?
And uh,
the rear aft,
I believe they say was a,
was making some noise and they thought it might be a little bit of jar.
So the copilot goes,
I'm going to go,
but I'm going to get up and I'm going to secure the door in the after section of
the airplane.
So the other guy says,
yeah,
I'm going to sit up here with my fucking seat belt on.
You go over there and uh,
learn about air pressure.
So this fucking dude goes back and he,
and in his efforts to secure the door aft of the airplane and the half section
of the airplane,
we need Augie to take your feet.
Please.
We haven't come to a full stop at the jet way yet.
Shout out you can't.
Um,
yeah,
he goes back there and
okay.
I Dunno.
He went to try to shut it and the fucking door pops open.
This is one of these small Cessna planes.
You know when you open the door,
like the stairs are on the inside of the door and you plop it down and then he
come down.
If some Hor puts a lei around your neck,
one of those planes,
then you go surfing and get fucking hit by a Tki or whatever,
one of those planes.
So the door pops open and this guy somehow as he goes to fall out,
he's falling out backwards.
Or maybe he grabbed the railing or whatever.
All I know is this fucking dude
went out the plane.
So the pilots upfront going,
holy fuck,
my friend just died.
So now he's got to land the plane,
which isn't a problem,
but that the problem is is that the door was ajar.
The door aft,
the APP section of the airplane is now a jar and he's wondering is it going to
drag?
Long story short,
he fucking lands the plane and when he gets out of the plane or walks to the
back of the plane,
he sees the copilot laying like head at the bottom of the stairs,
feet like still in the plane and his hands gripping the fucking skinny little
banisters.
So he tries to get this guy to let go and the guy is in like this catatonic
state and the fucking announcer,
the host of the show was saying it took the fucking fire department 20 minutes
to pry this guys fingers off of the Goddamn banister things because he had
what's known as a death grip.
I mean,
do you realize just mentally where you go in that moment where your brain
overrides everything other than keeping your heart beating and your respiratory
system going,
the only thing your brain is saying is don't fucking let go grab on to that
Shit.
It's just,
it's not even saying,
hang on,
I think it's just white noise.
It says,
hang on,
you have that thought and then it's going
nonstop until
you gradually come out of it.
And you look at a dike upside down.
Firefighters face that stupid mustache and the smell of Chili cause he cooks in
a firehouse telling you it's okay to let go now.
So with that long fucking story,
I bet this fat son of a bitch had a death grip on his segway,
went right to the bottom of the river.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You know what kills me is that thing was completely fucking useless.
Okay.
Completely useless.
I don't understand what,
what purpose it served
and that guy made he,
he became a billionaire.
The problem was is that they were 10 grand because you know,
God damn well if those fucking things were 500 bucks,
everyone would have one like a fucking iPod.
We would just be going down the street
looking like the beginning of one of those star wars movies.
You know where they have all the,
uh,
what does that,
what does that computer technology that they always use that ruins every fucking
movie.
That's what it looked like.
It looked like that computer technology that I don't know the name of and I
can't even tell you what it is cause my fucking internet isn't working.
So anyways,
the body of 62 year old James Helston Heselton and a segway personnel
transporter
were found in the river wharf.
I don't know what the fuck you said.
And he was pronounced dead at the same,
I'm sure he was with his fucking leg sticking up out of that river mud.
He might,
I bet he hit terminal velocity one in there like a fucking media.
There's probably some conspiracy theorists trying to say it was actually a
flying saucer and that just covering it up and they actually killed this guy.
Um,
police said a witness had reported seeing a man fall Sunday over a 30 foot drop
into the river near Boston spa,
140 miles north of London.
The incident is not,
the bleed is not believed to be suspicious.
Police said is it believed to be ridiculous.
I would've loved to been there.
Listen to those cops making those fucking jokes.
Just the awkward silence and then somebody fucking kills it with a joke.
It had to be something.
Yeah.
Uh,
that I can't think of right now.
You guys want to write a gel for that?
I'll read them next week.
The issue that's your,
that's your homework assignment.
What did the fucking London police say?
The first guy who made the joke about the segway guy who went fucking 200
something miles an hour into the bottom of a river bed with his own fucking
invention.
Has that ever happened before?
Has the weight of any great inventors invention ever.
Just sent them,
I guess a plane maybe.
Okay.
I mean,
that's some Frankincense Frankenstein Shit,
right?
I made you
really isn't good segues not alive.
Does anybody ever written a segway?
Now that I'm shitting all over?
See a,
the battery powered Segue,
which is stabilized by,
by gyro scopes,
was invented by Dean Kamen,
who founded the company in 1999 wait a minute.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's just a segue owner.
I thought this was the guy who fucking invented it.
My fault.
Oh,
he's just a wealthy businessman.
Jesus Christ.
Isn't that classic?
Make the fucking have half the God damn information.
Oh,
so it's not the guy who invented the fucking thing.
It's just some rich bassier to had one.
It didn't want to walk anymore.
He's like,
actually it looks like a hot shit.
You know,
like you drank some scotch and could tell a story.
Jesus Christ.
Now I'm starting to feel bad.
Little Fuck is Dean Cayman founder of the company in 1999.
The unique transporter relies on electricity to recharge his batteries and
travels or speeds up to 12 and a half miles an hour.
Okay.
I guess it's far more protective of the environment than other scooters and
automobiles.
The company says,
well,
Jesus Christ is a big fucking red flag.
According to us,
our products,
the best climbing,
it's 11 times more efficient than the average American car.
Yeah.
And fucking 30 times slower.
You know what,
Fuck Dean came in.
All right.
If you learn anything from this week's podcast,
Fuck Dean Cayman.
Alright.
So anyways,
I just got back from Nashville,
Tennessee,
Nashville,
fucking Tanis Shea.
And um,
I had a great God damn time out there.
I saw way more people out at my shows then the last time.
Um,
so let it go,
has been a great thing for me.
So I want to thank everybody who came out because a,
I have a tough time when I go down south for all you guys,
whoever,
you know,
send me emails going,
come to Mississippi,
come to north cackle lackey.
Come on bill.
You know you like college football,
come on to South Carolina.
Checkout DM getting Cox do a book and show problem is is I don't fucking talk.
Lock this so none of the other fuckers show up.
You guys don't fucking show up cause I'm not standing on stage with a camouflage
buttoned down shirt
and a pair of murders,
whatever the fuck you call them,
rubber boots you wear when you go out stomping around in the fucking mud.
I'm actually jealous of your ability to hunt.
Got a God damn animal.
Fix it.
No where to shoot it.
Right?
I would do the south if you mother fuckers would show up.
I have a great idea for a tour.
All right.
Playing different venues and it involves me going to some of my favorite teams
in the SCC.
For those of you who are only kind of like NFL football field,
like Cuba could become a bigger football fan.
I'm telling you don't sleep on college football.
Um,
it's absolute insanity.
Like at this point,
just about every stadium holds at least 80 to 100,000 people and it's fucking
packed.
Every goddamn one.
I have a goal.
I would go see any team in the SCC except for that Mississippi one where it's
80,000 people with cowbells.
I have no desire to go into that fucking environment.
I think I really,
I'm really not into the noisemakers.
That's why I don't work New Year's eve anymore.
You know,
all the,
all the women coming out there and the with dead drunk boyfriends and they got
that great Gatsby JP Morgan fucking hat on except it's plastic.
Oh,
why would you want s?
I mean,
is there anything more annoying than those little horns that people blow on new
years?
Hey,
do you remember Jim Carrey?
Dumb and dumber and he goes,
you want to hear the most annoying voice ever?
And that's what he sounded like.
And that's what it was.
So fucking funny to me because when he did that,
aside from the hilarious look on his face,
it immediately reminded me of standing on stage after I've done my set and I'm
counting down.
Billy might doing the countdown you might doing.
You mean you mind starting your New Year that way,
standing on stage.
Go a tad nine.
You know what,
I would,
I would mind doing that.
I resent this entire fucking thing.
And the worst was whenever you do the,
uh,
um,
when you play a shitty club that doesn't know what the fuck they doing,
the classic move that they make is they hand out the noisemakers before the
show.
Uh,
which,
you know,
I don't even need to get into the details of why that's so fucking horrific.
But I remember a long time ago I was working Nick's comedy stop and Boston and
uh,
Wbz the local fucking station there wanted to shoot something for New Year's eve
and we were shooting it in November.
So they handed out all the noise makers before any of us went up on stage.
I remember there was this a comedian,
Chris Edo,
and I had no idea,
you know,
I was so new,
I had no idea that that was going to be a problem.
And I just remembered when I saw the look on this seasoned headliner,
Chris Idos face the look of panic on his face.
And He came walking into the club.
And the second he heard of this look,
I had never seen on his face because he's always,
you know,
relax dude.
And he's going,
what?
Why do they have noise makers who,
he ended up the noisemakers.
He went right up to the person who ran the shit and Kudos to him,
got them to walk around the entire room and collect all the fucking noise makers
before we did the show,
which now I realize the brilliance of that move because we were going to go on
television and we would have bombed with in the background during our entire
fucking sets.
That was a long way to go.
But anyways,
so what I'm saying is,
uh,
I appreciate everybody coming down.
Hang on one second.
Did I just fucking blow this whole thing?
All right.
So evidently I didn't fuck it up.
I thought I'm,
I'm glad I didn't,
but I just saw this,
this plug was sticking way out.
Now how to fucking,
I'd be sticking out that far and it doesn't matter.
What is the purpose of having it in there.
See that,
look at me blaming technology rather than myself.
Um,
anyway,
so that was the new year story.
Shut up.
I'm going to pick up the ball and run with it.
So I was talking about as a college football,
if you want to get into college football,
I'm telling you,
watch the SCC for my money.
That's where it's at.
I fucking,
uh,
I love like every Goddamn team in there except for like Vanderbilt,
like teams that just suck every year.
But,
uh,
and I was tempted when I was in Nashville to drive the two and a half hours or
whatever,
just to go see the first,
like I dunno,
halfway through the third quarter of the Tennessee game.
Cause I've always wanted to go to a game out there,
you know,
with that Purina cat chow,
fucking look an end zone and a 100,000 people going absolutely insane.
Um,
but,
um,
I dunno,
I just,
my show is at seven,
then I was going to have to leave and I would have been fucking hammered.
I know I would've drank and I would've been driving across the 40,
40 fucking west going back to fucking Nashville.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
let's talk a little NFL football,
shall we?
Um,
another awesome week of football and a,
this week I actually gambled a little bit.
I got a little running thing going with the,
another buddy of mine,
another comic Buddy of mine were rob.
We're basically,
we're picking three games each week and you've got to bet against a spread.
And I went,
uh,
what did I go?
I think I went,
whoa.
I went one and two,
but if I teased him,
I would have won.
I think I would have,
this is what I had,
uh,
the team I won,
I had the bills getting 14 and a half,
which I almost fucking lost.
But,
uh,
I just,
I hate the Patriots.
Defense is fucking horrific.
You know,
we let up a ton of yards against the bangles.
We let up.
Like,
I can't remember that Joe was a jets game.
Was it 30?
Was it over 30?
Is it 38?
I can't fucking remember when we got our asses kicked a fucking defense looked
horrible in that game and our deep,
we just let up 30 points to the bills.
So sad to say Patriot fans,
myself included.
I see us going,
like if this trend continues at best,
I think maybe we're a nine and 17 and a,
I was joking with my buddy watching the patriots.
Uh,
you know,
we look like we look like a fucking,
like a 2000 corvette.
That's the only way to describe it.
You know what I mean?
Where it can still fucking go zero to 60 really fast.
But it has a little of that get got,
got,
get,
got fucking sound.
You know,
still a corvette.
But you know,
it's been beat on a little bit.
I Dunno,
I don't even know how to explain it.
It's just like,
we seem to have a lot of the tools,
but like we have no fucking pass rush,
great against the rabbit.
And uh,
I don't know that one play where,
I mean,
who the first of all,
who the fuck is the bill's quarterback?
That's what really scared me.
You know what I mean?
Some people just have a look in their face.
They look like a quarterback and then I'll do other people look like they work
at home depot and whatever the fuck that guy's name was.
Fitzgerald.
I don't know what his gut guys,
Goddamn name.
I was watching it at a sports bar.
What's the first half in,
uh,
in Nashville.
And they had the sound down because everyone was watching obviously the titans
game cause I was in Tennessee and um,
I just kept looking at that guy's face in his red fucking beard.
And I was just like,
is that Eric Hippel?
Who,
who the fuck is that?
And he was just,
he was just going right down the goddamn field against us.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
This is this weird part of the year where a few,
if you gamble,
because you're trying to figure out,
you know,
what your team is,
which is really,
if you had any brains,
you wouldn't gamble for like the first six weeks of the season until you got
some sort of consistency.
Right.
Because as much as I talk shit about the jets,
it's like they kicked the shit out of the Patriots.
You start taking,
well wait a minute,
maybe all this talking is for real.
But then it's like you kicked the shit out of a team that
yeah,
that gave up 30 points to the bills,
you know?
And then you go down to the dolphins,
you played the dolphins and the dolphins have no fucking offense to speak of.
And it,
you basically couldn't put them away until the final fucking 20 seconds.
If that guy had a fucking God damn arm,
that would've been it,
you know?
Well,
no,
you can't say that cause I needed a two point conversion.
But,
um,
I dunno.
So,
okay,
well let me finish with the bets I had then I had the fucking lions getting 13
and a half.
I lost that one.
And then I had the saints given three and a half.
I went against my,
uh,
my theory about divisional rivalries and,
I was gonna bet the dolphins,
but I just didn't like them given three to the jets,
just cause the jets have a great,
uh,
a great defense.
And I didn't like the fact that the dolphins had no offense.
So I stayed away from that one.
And if I had to,
you know what it was,
I think I was leaning towards taking the jets with the points and I just
couldn't fucking get myself to,
then I will be rooting for the jets and I just couldn't get myself to do it.
So having said all that,
the team that I think right now,
it looks the best to me is the Pittsburgh Steelers.
They have three and oh with the third stinked third string quarterback and their
defense looks fucking unbelievable.
And that they,
like they say that's what wins championships.
All right.
And I got a couple of emails,
some jets fans going,
you still going to keep hating on the jets,
you know,
typical jet fans,
they're all excited because they're two in one,
three games into the season.
Right?
And all fat boy wrote on that bus,
they're going to the super bowl.
Um,
he says,
I know you hate the jets,
but are you going to let that cloud your objectivity and pick the jets to lose
for the next 13 weeks?
No,
I'm not.
And yet,
and that's actually a fair question because I hate New York teams to such a
level that it will cloud my objectivity,
but uh,
I wouldn't,
uh,
I wouldn't get too excited there buddy.
Boy,
you guys have,
I mean,
the only team I think that you really played,
dad had a serious like playoff defense was the ravens and they held you to like
nine points.
So,
you know,
I'm sure you're excited about beating the patriots,
but be honest with yourself.
True football fans.
The fact that the team that you kicked the shit out of just let up 30 points to
the Goddamn jet.
I have bills.
I mean,
do you think jets,
do you guys think that you're going to do that?
I'm actually going to that game by the way,
the bills,
jets game.
I am going to that game because I'm doing a theater in Buffalo,
the Saturday night right before the game and I'm going to hang out.
I'm going to go there and with all my heart I'm going to root against the jets
even though I know the bills are going to fucking lose.
Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
is that all boring to people who aren't into fucking sports?
So I still,
I would say at this point I would say the two top contenders,
I would say the Steelers too early to say the chiefs,
whether they're for real or not and just cause the cults seem to win 13 games
every year,
but they always blow it in the fucking playoffs.
But the best thing that jets have going for them,
I seriously think is the fact that Sanchez hasn't thrown an interception yet.
And yes,
I hope that jinx is him into throwing five next week.
But if he's got to play like that,
you know,
uh,
I dunno,
I just did it.
You're not a fucking Superbowl team.
Fuck the jets.
All right,
let's get to some youtube videos.
No,
you know what I gotta I gotta tell you something that's been fucking bugging the
shit out of me.
Okay?
You have to have a friend.
You just fucking outgrow them.
You know what I mean?
I don't even want to get into this shit.
You just fucking,
you just,
it's like,
you know,
you're chugging along,
you're doing your shit,
you'll life's going good and their life isn't going good.
And then eventually what that ends up happening is all of a sudden they just
start making little snide remarks about your life,
you know?
And then he got to sit there and go,
wow,
that was fucking weird.
That,
and I do it.
I was just fucking around.
I'm sorry man,
I'm fucking,
they always end up apologizing.
Nah,
I'm just going through some shit and blah,
blah,
blah.
And then it's just kind of becomes more and more and more.
I,
you know,
I got this fucking buddy of mine and it's just like,
he's one of these fucking guys says,
life is all fucked up.
Just think of every dumb thing that you could do.
Every dumb thing that you could do to fuck up your life.
You know,
smoking weed,
gambling,
uh,
you know,
being high at work,
flunking drug tests,
losing jobs,
getting drunk,
falling down,
fucking up your face,
that type of shit,
that type of Shit,
right?
One of those fucking guys calls you up with a crisis every six fucking weeks.
Dude,
you'd have to believe with him.
It's never their fault.
One of those fucking guys where it's just like,
all right,
you know,
you choose to live your life that way.
That's how you live your life.
But then they fucking come in and make snide remarks at you and then you want to
come back and just fucking unload on him.
Yeah.
You know,
it'd be like,
dude,
you're fucking a drug test working at a goddamn fruit stand.
You fucking loser.
You know,
why don't you come home and blow some more fucking weed smoker?
Do your families face as you give them,
you know,
$3 for the fucking week.
You know,
that's what you want to say,
but you don't,
you wait til your podcast.
Yeah man.
It's just like,
ah,
that's one of those,
that's one of those things you guys,
do you guys have any stories like that?
Cause I really don't want to talk any more about this,
but I know you do.
Come on.
Some of you guys out there,
you're doing well,
right?
Maybe somebody you were friends with when you were both struggling with isn't
doing well yet.
All right.
But they're so busy focusing on,
on,
on what you're doing that uh,
you know,
they start giving you this roundabout shit.
Oh my God,
it's fucking dude
saw my special,
right.
At least me,
this fucked up message.
Right?
And then just click hangs up and add alcohol and back for like,
you know,
10 days or whatever week or so.
I call the dude up.
I'm like,
listen to it.
Why?
What the fuck was it?
That message,
you know,
it's like if you're not happy with your own life,
fix your life.
The fuck.
He taken it out on me for,
you know,
and then he,
and then he texted me back some bullshit about a dude.
I was just joking.
Don't be so insecure,
you know?
And it's just a really,
is that,
is that what the fuck?
And then I go to column and his phone is off
fucking idiot.
I'm insecurity or the guy's got to fucking smoke weed all the God damn time.
Turn your life into a movie because you can't fucking deal.
Okay.
Looking at the God damn ceiling.
Hey,
you fucking moron.
Anyway,
so let's plow ahead here.
Plowing ahead,
plowing ahead.
If you got any fucking stories like that.
This is just getting negative.
Um,
let me,
Oh,
do I want to fucking unload on this guy?
I want to fucking unload on this guy.
I really do.
And I'm going to say,
I just know I'm going to say shit.
Then that's just going to be the end of it.
And,
uh,
that's why I'm not,
that's why I'm just choosing my world's words very carefully,
still saying things really conti.
Um,
but I'm not worried about him here in this cause he's too fucking high till even
he doesn't even know how to use a computer,
you know,
so I basically could go off on whatever.
Send me your stories.
So Cathartic Lee,
I can fucking,
I in a Cathartic way,
if I'm using that word correctly,
I can go off on your friends rather than my own.
All right,
let's get into some advice.
The gas bill section of the week.
Uh,
Bill,
I'd appreciate it.
Uh,
if you could give my friend some advice concerning a girl.
My friend is in college and works part time at a restaurant as a waiter.
Within the past few weeks,
they hired a girl to host and bus tables on some of the days he works.
I think you going to say literally this girl was hosting and bussing tables.
I was just like,
ah,
that's kind of nasty.
Uh,
I told you guys that story right when I was working for that restaurant that was
going out of business and at one point I was the grill shift.
I don't know,
I told this story but I actually worked on a mesquite grill with one of those
top chef's hats on,
glassed in.
Like I knew what the fuck I was doing and I also bus tables and wash the dishes,
you know in this like I'd cook the meal and as I was cooking it I would be
watching other people trying to see if they were done eating and when they were,
I would duck down behind the grill,
take off the hat and my apron and underneath it I had that half a Tuxedo that
you were in a restaurant that tries to look like it's fancy and I would come out
there,
my face red from working on the grill,
I remember being so God damn hot in there.
I bust the table and then I would go back,
throw out the food,
scrape off the plates and load up the load and it fucking put it in the
dishwasher,
not wash my hands because I didn't have time because I had to run back to make
sure the medium rare burger didn't become medium.
That's what I thought you were suggesting there.
Um,
so keep an eye on the employees.
People.
Make sure there's no double agents at the fucking restaurants you'd go to or you
do not want to eat their little tip.
All right.
Here we go.
Plowing ahead.
Uh,
what the hell,
where are we?
Uh,
they developed,
they quickly developed a relationship where he would hang out in her dorm
between classes for hours at a time doing what college kids do.
I guess he really thought that she was the one.
Uh,
I tried to tell him to slow down a bit because nothing good comes from obsessing
in that early pre relationship,
uh,
period.
Anyways,
a week into it.
She tells him that she's really not looking for a relationship because she
doesn't want to get tied in with the guy and get distracted from school.
They pretty much agreed to be friends with benefits in parentheses.
He says,
I hate that term.
Yeah,
they're going to be fuck buddies.
Um,
sounds reasonable to me.
Then I guess he overheard something during work or he had called her and this
other guy answered or something answer the phone.
Anyway,
he finds out that she's already going out with some other dude,
like a full on relationship.
So now my friend has to work with this cunt and try to go on like nothing
happened,
happened.
You know what's great is,
why am I voice always cracks was cause I fucking scream my act the night before
actually the two nights before.
So he has to go around and act like nothing happened.
Uh,
what should he say to her?
I feel bad for him since he would talk on and on about her,
about this girl every day.
I appreciate the insight bill.
If you read this.
Um,
all right.
What should he say to her?
Nothing.
You shouldn't say anything.
Uh,
she's a young girl who doesn't know how to get out of a relationship yet,
or maybe she's afraid to be alone.
I don't know what,
but,
uh,
what he should do is,
he should stop attempting to fucker.
Okay.
His best move is just to be cool.
It's going to be hard because he likes her to just be like,
hey,
what's going on?
And,
uh,
and kind of leave it at that.
And if she comes up like,
well,
how come you're not talking to me?
No,
there's something weird what's going on?
And just be like,
look,
I'm not trying to be a jerk,
but I kind of got wind that you're,
that you have a boyfriend and a,
so,
you know,
I don't mess with girls who have boyfriends.
That's all.
I'm not judging you or anything,
but uh,
yeah.
So,
you know,
I actually Kinda liked you and uh,
when I found out you had it,
I guess that's the first thing you should do.
There you go.
Putting the cart before the horse.
Okay.
He should find out.
But I,
I really wouldn't find out from her find out from someone who kind of knows and
just be like,
she has a boyfriend.
Right.
And then,
and then when you've clarified that she has a boyfriend,
then just keep the conversation short.
Hey,
how you doing?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And eventually when you don't try to,
when he,
your friend doesn't try to fuck her again,
I'll hook up or whatever.
She's going to be like a,
you know,
what's going on.
Just things seem like it's going on with you.
Hey you,
hey.
You know,
they do that shit trying to fill.
Yes.
It's a matter is that I does everything all right between like wings or
the code.
Cause I just kind of noticed,
you know,
you just kind of let me say hello to me,
but you used to stop me,
you know,
maybe give me a compliment,
say,
look man,
you can't properly,
oh,
that head of that bullshit.
Right.
And just be like a,
yeah.
You know,
I just kind of heard through the grapevine that you have a boyfriend,
a serious full on relationship boyfriend.
So,
uh,
kind of threw me for a loop because you never brought it up.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
That,
um,
Kay.
Uh,
all right.
I should have said something and right there,
you know,
she just trying to work her way out of it with the long pauses between what
she's saying.
Yeah.
That bullshit and just,
I just don't say anything and just look at her and she stammers her way through
it.
If she does,
she might be one of these people who like,
she's probably going to just turn around and fucking walk away because a,
she doesn't like confrontations.
She could deal with confrontation.
She'd get out of that fucking relationship,
be like,
look,
I'm not happy.
Okay.
I,
yeah.
So get your books and your Letterman jacket and fucking beat it.
You know,
whatever the hell you got to say.
Um,
yes,
I,
did I give any advice or did I just imitate this girl that I never met?
That's what I would do.
I would confirm from someone who knows her really well,
that she has a boyfriend and when she,
and,
and just be nice to her,
hey,
what's going on?
You don't want to create any fucking shit at work because you need the job.
You don't want to lose your,
your,
uh,
any money or whatever.
Look,
at the end of the day,
you fucking banged her.
All right?
So that's a plus.
Uh,
no,
that's not the kind of girl you want to marry.
Someone would be in a full on fucking relationship and would,
would,
uh,
try to set up where you're,
you're,
you're fucking somebody else on the side.
That's not the mother,
your kids,
you know,
I mean,
grant,
the only thing saving her,
she's young,
so she has some growing up to do.
But uh,
yeah,
you don't wanna be involved in that because next thing you know,
you're the guy in the fall on relationship with her and she's banging some other
way to run the side when she does not a break up with you.
So I would stay away from that girl and uh,
that's it.
Then I would also stop fucking people where I work.
That's another thing.
You don't shit where you eat,
where you eat.
It's something you do when you're young,
you know,
you just,
you just fucking your vicinity and your facility.
But uh,
yeah,
I would try to avoid doing that.
So that's,
that's basically my advice.
Do you want me to say it again?
I just keep saying the same thing over and over again in different order.
That's a,
that's how I would handle that situation.
And uh,
and with that,
I think I'm pretty much out of information that people have given to me this
week.
Let me do the math here.
I had done 36 minutes.
I owe you another 14 the fuck am I going to talk about if I could get on the
Goddamn Internet.
I tried to fucking pick some teams next week.
Would you guys like tonight Green Bay and the bears,
this is one of these classic early season match ups.
We're going to get to see who's for real.
You know which bears team is going to show up.
The one that technically lost to the lions in the first fucking week or the one
that manhandled the cowboys last week.
I Dunno.
I like Mike Martz is a fucking offensive coordinator.
MMM.
If I was a gambling man cause I just do bullshit,
you know,
we're basically,
it's like a hundred bucks for the year.
Whoever has the best fucking record.
I know it's a pussy bet.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
but if I had to gamble tonight,
this might be,
I,
if I would take the home team,
I would take the fucking home team on this one.
Well,
I don't know how to fucking you say that bill without seeing the God damn point
spread.
That's a great point.
That is a great fucking point.
Come on,
get me online.
You Pale his fucking money for this shit.
Whatever you guys wanted some youtube videos for the week.
I got some great ones.
I have some great ones.
Here we go,
uh,
African American man hoses off a white woman who called him and it's basically
the n word.
All right.
You have to watch this video.
It's fucking phenomenal.
And,
uh,
like I always say,
if you want to,
uh,
rather than search all of these yourself,
just go to the m m podcast.com t h e m m podcast.com,
the MM podcast.com,
the official a fan page for the Monday morning podcast.
We'll have all the youtube videos right in a fucking row
and you can just,
you can just blow right through them.
All right.
So look up African American man hoses off a white woman who called him,
uh,
the n word and uh,
it's just awesome.
She's in one of those motorized,
you know,
those motorized carts that people who can walk but you know,
don't feel like it drive,
I don't understand them.
It's different than a wheelchair.
Wheelchair for the most part means you can't walk.
But those motorized carts mean,
uh,
I dunno,
I think you can't walk for long.
Yeah.
You can't walk for long distances and a,
so these are sort of drive and you have an inability to stand up on a segway and
you're worried that you're going to drive off a cliff and go into a fucking
river.
So anyways,
guys,
Washington is fucking 85 caprice classic I believe.
And this woman just fuck it is on the other side of the street yelling at him
and he just starts fucking,
you know what I love?
It's not that he just sort of like,
you know,
back and forth poses a rough,
like he's spraying a garden,
he full on blast her in the face and just holds it there.
And it's really great because it's the whole like with black people used to,
you know,
we had to march for civil rights in the fucking evil white people would be
holding the hose in their face.
It's come full circle now.
Here we are 40 fucking years later,
50 years almost.
And now the black dude is holding it and in the white person's face.
Uh,
but it's just a garden hose.
So it's hilarious.
He's just spraying or just not moving it.
Go say it again,
say it again,
bitch.
It's fucking awesome.
Ah,
and when she drives away in the end and is still giving him shit and she's
soaking wet,
I mean it was just one of the fucking great laughs.
I've had an a let's just one of the,
I just,
it was awesome.
I just fucking die and laugh and watching it and I'm all right.
Here's the next one.
This one is actually really,
I can't believe this guy didn't get hurt really bad,
uh,
airbag test in Russia.
MMM.
This guy has to go at least nine feet in the fucking air and lands like a
Goddamn rag doll and his friends are just laughing at him.
I mean,
just the concussive force alone,
what that would do to your eardrums is a,
is beyond me.
It,
speaking of that,
a reoccurring theme on this podcast,
I've brought it up a few times because I've done a permanent damage to my ears
from seeing bands live music and,
uh,
playing drums.
Um,
I'm telling you because I was out in Nashville,
my buddy out there took me out to some clubs that I always have the earplugs.
And I was actually talking to this guy who was about my age and,
uh,
from what his friends was saying,
you know,
God,
a lot of ass back in the day.
All right.
And he was,
see,
saw that it had on ear plugs.
He goes,
what?
do you wear those all the time?
I go,
yeah,
I tried to.
He goes,
yeah,
because recently I went to the doctor and the guy said,
hey,
uh,
were you ever in the military?
And he said No.
And he asked,
did you work in,
in,
in a machine shop?
Basically asking all those fucking questions.
And the guy just said no.
And I'm telling you,
it was from years of going out to bars where they got the music cranked way too
fucking loud and uh,
you know,
that shit we hitting on the girl.
Do you live around here?
You literally leaning into her ear,
you're screaming into her fucking ear.
Like,
just imagine if there was no music on and somebody did that to you,
you punch him in the face.
But when you're in those clubs,
the music is so fucking loud that someone has to get right near your ear and
yell into it just so you can hear him.
So I'm telling you,
MMM,
I didn't know how the fuck I got on this subject.
Well,
I guess the airbag test,
you know,
I know you're young and then you got ear plugs.
What do you fucking queer?
I'm telling you,
put those goddamn things in.
You've ever one experiment,
one night,
just where one where one and stand in there for a fucking half hour and walk out
and take the other one out and feel the difference.
Your,
you're the ear that didn't have one is going to feel like it's underwater.
And every time you do that you're doing permanent.
Like can I have your ears ring out of nowhere?
You just walking down the street and they go,
Ooh.
Yeah,
that means you have,
you have permanent hearing damage.
Uh,
so where are your earplugs?
Their kids,
he's as crisis.
One of the fucking Corny is things I've ever said,
but I dunno.
It's driven people to suicide.
So because it just keeps getting louder.
All right,
here's another raw,
he's another fucking youtube video.
This one is unbelievable.
It's called Uks best free runners and a,
it's like a six minute video.
Usually.
I don't like videos this long,
but this is,
these are these people who basically,
um,
run and jump off of like,
you know,
out of second story windows land and roll and keep going and do like a fucking
backflip and then run up the side of a tree and then do another back flip that
fucking unbelievable.
And the only thing that this video is missing is I want to see a free runner.
Get chased by a cop on foot because this dude,
one of these guys,
he fucking runs at,
uh,
you know,
those,
those big,
um,
when you go down to like a,
uh,
like a,
a wharf,
if you're not doing a drug deal or whatever,
you know,
those big containers that they basically lift off of the ship and they can put
on the back of an 18 wheeler.
That's what it basically looks like.
It looks like that the back of an 18 wheeler,
this fucking dude is running full speed at it and then runs two steps like Bo
Jackson up the side of the thing and then grabs the top of it and does a pull up
and pulls himself up and this is all one motion continues to run and then jumps
like a six feet,
six foot gap over to this other building where he's got where he's got to reach
up,
jump to the ledge,
does another pull up and now he's up on the building.
All of that takes about a second and a half.
And I would just,
would have loved to seen a cop chasing this dude and he just wouldn't,
you know,
even if he wanted to shoot him,
he couldn't have got the gun out quick enough and it would just would have been
like,
yeah,
pursuits over.
I don't know.
I,
he was in front of me and then he ran up a fucking building.
Now Dude,
I'm telling you,
he ran up a building.
I didn't have time to show them.
Well you fucking chase a check that out is another quick one.
Ladies teeth fall out during divorce court.
That's pretty much self explanatory.
Um,
and then I've got a couple of Tourette's videos.
There's a guy with Tourette's,
Tourette's,
Karaoke,
um,
tourettes karaoke and the guys do an rdms losing my religion.
It's fucking hilarious.
Then there's a,
there's another one out there called,
uh,
the best of Tourette's guy.
And,
um,
I,
I'm,
I'm convinced the guy's an actor because he doesn't have Tourette's.
And as far as you know,
being on the opiate Anthony show and being around people with Tourette's for a
long fucking time,
it's sort of a rep repetition of either weird noises and there is cursing.
But the way this guy's cursing,
it's tourists.
It's not Tourette's,
Tourette's.
It's not tourettes,
but it's fucking hilarious.
So look up Tourette's guy.
Um,
and that's it.
That's what I got this week.
I'm sorry.
I have the windows open.
We got a heat wave out here.
If you can hear that fucking lawn mower
of a,
the dude down the street.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
I'm a kite and this fucking podcast.
What do we got here?
30 minutes and 16.
That's 46.
All right.
I need another four minutes.
I apologize.
This has been a fucking lame on this week.
Um,
what have I got to?
Let me hide my gigs that I have coming up.
Oh wait,
I'm back online.
No,
but now it's back off.
Jesus Christ.
What kind of life am I living?
Kind of life.
Am I living here?
I can't even get on my own.
God Damn podcast.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait.
I'm using the schedule here using my schedule.
All right.
This is what I have coming up this weekend.
I am going to be in Albany,
New York at the egg,
the egg.
You sons of bitches.
All you people live in upstate New York who were like,
come to Syracuse,
come to Albany,
do the Lake Ontario play house dude.
Um,
and I always play New York City.
I am doing two out of the way gigs in upstate New York.
I'm doing the egg Albany,
which a lot of people don't realize is the capital of New York,
Albany.
And then the next night I am at the,
uh,
the Buffalo.
The fuck is this.
Let me see what we got here.
Buffalo Center for the Arts University at Buffalo Center for the arts.
Uh,
both shows are at 8:00 PM.
Please come out,
please come out and uh,
to
show you what kind of a sports fan I am.
I'm hanging out the next day.
I'm going to the bills jets game and I don't fly out to the next day.
And the buffalo Sabres a play in the fly is so I'm going to that game too.
Why the fuck wouldn't you,
why wouldn't you?
And,
um,
I also have some cool radio coming up.
I'm doing an Adam Carolla's podcast on Wednesday.
Um,
October 29th.
Adam Carolla,
as far as I know,
has the biggest podcast on the Internet.
Um,
the guy's killing it,
so I'm going to be on that on Wednesday,
September 29th,
I'm sorry,
and later on that day I'm also going to be doing a,
Jamie Foxx is show on Sirius satellite radio,
the foxhole.
And I believe Jamie's not going to be there,
but earthquake and uh,
who do I forget?
Who else is going to be there?
Um,
check that one out.
And I'm going to be a doctor.
Drew Show love line on October 6th.
Hi,
look at me moving up in the radio world.
Those are three famous fucking people's shows I'm doing.
Um,
later on this month I'm coming out to Minnesota in Chicago to do one nighters at
theaters and these tickets are fucking selling tremendously.
So if you're thinking to go and get the tickets now because,
uh,
I am blown away by the response out there and play in the Pantages theater in
Minneapolis,
Minnesota on October 22nd,
I'm playing the Vic Theater in Chicago,
Illinois the following weekend.
And uh,
and here's a quick date that I opened.
I'm doing one night only at the funny bone in Saint Louis on October 30th,
October 30th.
Everybody one night only.
So come on down,
check out my new hour.
All my material is 100% different from,
uh,
from the let it go special.
And speaking of that,
let it go.
We'll be aired again on comedy central October 1st.
Please watch it.
Um,
if you can watch it live,
because that,
those are the only ones that I get credit for as far as the ratings.
Um,
you guys want to hear a little behind the behind the curtain show business shit.
This is how it works.
Uh,
how the ratings work is they don't count Tivo watches if you record it and then
you watch it,
they don't count it because you know,
when I know that you blow through the commercials and ratings exists so they can
figure out how much they can charge advertisers so they can figure out how many
people are actually watching the goddamn commercial.
So,
um,
October 1st comedy central is showing,
uh,
let it go again.
And,
uh,
that's pretty much it.
Oh,
and a Halloween,
I'm hanging out.
I'm going to the rams game in St Louis,
so there you go.
That is it.
And just so if you want to plan ahead,
I got the funny bone and Columbus,
Ohio,
November 12th,
13th and 14th,
and then a,
I'm in DC at the listener auditorium on uh,
November 19th.
And then I'm doing Foxwoods,
right?
Foxwoods day.
You Go Foxwoods on November 20th.
There's another one,
people don't come to Connecticut.
I'm in Connecticut,
November 20th and a,
and then the last one I will give you is I'm at the Moore Theater in Seattle,
November 27th.
And,
uh,
the,
this is a huge little mini run for me.
This is the first time I actually tried to do theaters on my own.
So I'm really excited about that.
All this and this.
How much of a sports fan I am,
I'm flying in the Friday night,
uh,
to do the radio,
so you know,
to the radio to hype the,
the,
uh,
the Damn Gig.
And I'm actually going to drive down and go to that Trailblazer Hornets game.
And then I'm going to the cities Seattle Seahawks game on the Sunday afterwards.
And I brought all of that up is the lovely Nia.
Just walked in here.
The lovely Nia just walked in here.
Does that make you upset than US spending an extra day on the road to go to a
football game?
Huh?
Come here.
Come in here.
It's not until the end of next month.
I like football.
I love you.
But I liked football.
Come here.
Come over here.
Oh,
she just slammed down her purse as if to say,
you know you don't like the rams.
Okay.
Saint Louis Rams.
Let me tell you about the rams there.
One of the original teams that made up the NFL and uh,
they were in Los Angeles for a while and that didn't work out well.
It worked out for a while and then they,
then they,
then they moved down.
I don't care to Anaheim where Disneyland is one of the happy places and then
after Awhile Punch you in your patronizing red face.
Come on.
If I fight,
this is a technique that,
you know what?
I have OCD.
All right.
If I go to that rams game,
first of all,
the only team in,
in the,
in,
in the Midwest,
first of all,
you don't have OCD.
Stop being dramatic.
There are people who actually have OCD and they want to kill themselves.
You don't have OCD.
You like going to football games,
but it doesn't mean you have OCD.
You
see that that's what you need in your life.
You need a woman can put you in your place when you're being ridiculous.
Was I being ridiculous?
Yes.
You just gave me the look really
and what?
Stop cursing on the podcast.
You know I had enough of you see that the supposed to be honest in a fucking
relationship.
I told you what I'm doing rather than coming home,
I'm going to the fucking rams game.
Oh,
here she comes.
To be honest with you,
the fact that you've been on the road constantly and are choosing to stay out
longer is really fucking rude.
I have two weeks off.
Yeah,
exactly where you should be home.
I'm going to be home during those two weeks.
These are,
these fucking games are in like November except for the fine go.
I don't want to see you.
Anyone except for the two in October.
Uh,
she just gave me the finger.
Are you doing,
you're not going to do the pumpkin bread or anything.
I'm going to do the Pumpkins and I'm also gonna make the Pumpkin bread.
I'm big on Halloween.
Everybody.
I like it.
You don't have to,
but you don't have to buy any gifts.
You know all these kids coming up the stairs dressed like Godzilla.
Yeah,
it's adorable.
And I make it.
How great was the punk and Brennan made last year?
It was great.
You make great pumpkin bread.
You're a great baker.
That was all insulting.
It was great.
It was great pumpkin bread.
You're great.
But you know what,
you know,
I don't,
you know what,
I,
I'm smart enough not to engage in this with you.
This,
Ooh,
this is just your way saying that you love me and you miss me,
so I'm not gonna engage in this.
I love you too.
Okay.
Ah,
see,
figure that one out.
Go,
go,
go.
Pour yourself a bowl of cereal.
Get out of my face.
I'm going to finish this up.
Oh,
I'll be that fucking cheap shot.
It was a woman ever just square up and it just go,
let's go.
They don't,
they wait till you're not looking in your fucking throw a punch.
Fucking cheap.
It was nice.
It was right where my appendix used to be.
Did you have your appendix out?
Um,
yes I did.
I had it out back in the day,
way back in the day on those little house in the prairie days where you almost
died of it because people didn't know what's wrong with you walking around.
You face the same color as glue.
Your Dad just go and I'll throw out your bed.
You're being a baby.
I feel like there's somebody had visible stabbing me in my side.
Ah,
come on.
Come on.
Stop it.
Grow Up.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
so please,
um,
checkout,
checkout my special October 1st if you missed it and please buy tickets to my
shows.
I have a brand new hour.
I have a big theater tour coming up and uh,
you know what else I did mentioned?
I didn't mention this shit.
All right,
because this is a high book myself on the road.
I have to whisper here.
So Nia doesn't figure this shit out.
That how I booked myself on the road is take like the funny bone and Columbus,
Ohio.
All right,
I'm going to be there the 12th,
13th and 14th of November.
Why did we pick this weekend?
You know what I mean?
Who the fuck?
Why the fuck would you ever go to Columbus,
Ohio?
There's only one fucking reason and that's to go to Ohio state buckeyes game.
Other than that,
there's no fucking reason unless you want to join a militia or maybe use that as
your base camp as you drive down to go see that chick who plays with the
pretenders and I forget where the fuck she's from.
So anyways,
Ohio state is playing Penn state that day.
And,
uh,
I'm really rolling the dice because of the flex schedule,
which is basically if Ohio state and Penn state are ranked really high,
that game will then become an eight o'clock game.
So not only will I not get to go to the game,
nobody will show up to my fucking show because everyone's going to be at the
fucking Goddamn Ohio state game.
All right?
And I'm telling you people,
if you,
if you come from like a town I come from,
which is a professional sports team,
a professional sports town,
you have no fucking idea how insane it can get.
Like as much as they,
they talk about the Yankees,
red sox rivalry and how fucking insane it can't hold a candle to Ohio state,
Michigan.
If you don't believe me,
Hbo did a documentary on it and it,
it's,
it's absolutely fucking insane.
And I'll tell you right now,
if Fenway Park or Yankee Stadium Somehow held a hundred thousand fucking people,
they wouldn't sell it out.
You couldn't get 100,000 people to go to that.
I don't think you'd get 100,000 people to go to a fucking world series game.
Um,
but college football,
they'll fucking have 100,000 people just to watch.
Ohio state kicked the shit out of bowling green.
They don't give a shit.
They just show up.
Um,
anyways,
that is the podcast for this week
and I realized that a,
I didn't address that.
My podcast has been taken off of iTunes.
Uh,
I believe that was something that I did.
I figure out what it is,
but um,
I have some people working on it and I didn't even address it because I'm hoping
it's just gonna be a one week problem and a,
that is it.
That's the podcast for this week.
A good luck to everybody.
I know who the fucking patriots have next week we have the dolphins and I'll
tell you right now,
I don't like that game.
I don't fucking like it until we have a God damn defense.
I don't like any game that we're playing.
I don't like it,
but I'm loving Hernandez.
I'm loving that guy.
But I'm hoping Mohs is going to get some more touches because he's going to
start bitching or something.
I don't fucking know.
God Damn it.
That's my prediction right now.
The way we've played the first three weeks and all the points we let up,
I'm saying we're going to go nine and seven.
Um,
and we might even be tied for second with the dolphins and they might even be 10
and six jets might go 11 and five.
Um,
I got to wait till the jets actually play another contender.
I know we're playing the Steelers.
I don't know if the jets play them,
but that's,
that's going to be a big game when Ben Roethlisberger is back.
I'll tell you what,
jet fans,
I'll tell you this right now.
Okay.
And know that the reason why I gave the jet so much shit A's because they're
from New York and also because they were talking so much fucking shit.
That's what happens.
And noticed after they got their fucking asses kicked,
they didn't get their asses kicked but they lost.
Where's all the shit talking?
Now they shut the fuck up,
which is actually me hating the jets.
I kind of wished that they beat the ravens cause they still would have been
talking and then they would have been in a situation like the 2007 Patriots
where the entire league wants to kick the shit out of you.
And eventually someone does and you go home sad with your head hanging down.
But I will tell you this,
if you guys do play the fucking Steelers,
all right,
at Big Ben is back and uh,
you know,
and you guys beat him then I will say you guys are for are for real.
Okay.
All right.
And as much as you,
New Yorkers can't fucking stand,
stand me.
You gotta admit that's how you have to be.
You can't just say you the shit and not be the shit.
And then everybody just says you're the shit unless you Peyton Manning,
of course,
who could just do no fucking wrong.
Right?
Right.
Once again,
he's off to a ds on a fucking tear,
putting up ridiculous numbers.
And I'll tell you this fucking cold fence.
If Peyton manning wants three super bowls with the regular season stats that
he's put up,
if you want to say that he's the best guy who ever played that position at that
point,
I would have a hard time argument because he would,
he would have that final piece that he needed,
which was leading your team in the playoffs to the promise land as opposed to
getting them to the promise land.
You're right there at the gates,
a Wally world.
And then throwing a pick six to fucking John Candy and he runs it back 60 yards.
All right,
so all you fucking guys,
cause you guys love your team so much.
You're not even listening to what I'm saying.
All said was rex Ryan is his out of his fucking mind.
He's not as confident as he acts.
He cries himself to sleep with a fucking gallon ice cream every night.
And uh,
he has,
uh,
a as a,
a chronic need to be liked.
And I am right on all of those fucking points.
I don't give a shit.
And also said that all this shit you were talking was bullshit,
which was proven in the first fucking week when you lost.
All right?
So when you,
when you beat a legitimate super bowl contender,
which you have yet to fucking play,
all you've played so far is one team that has a playoff level defense and you
didn't beat them all.
Right?
Really?
Do you think that dolphins are going to win the Superbowl?
Do you really think you're going to run into them again in the fucking playoffs
with their no-name QB?
You're not.
Do you think the Patriots are going to do anything letting up 30 points of
fucking game than not?
I know that because Bella check is still there and Tom Brady is still there.
You think that there's still the o four or o seven paths?
They're not,
they're not.
This is,
this is a whole new fucking team.
And um,
and at,
let me,
it's fucking ridiculous.
We have to score like 35 38 points to get a victory.
We scored 38 points on the bills,
38 points.
And it was still a nail biter right down to the fucking end.
All right,
whatever.
It's fucking frustrating and you guys couldn't beat the dolphins to the last
guy.
Didn't play the game and you guys are sitting there talking super bowl.
Is that what you ice cream fucking eat and fags down there in New York?
Is that what you're doing?
Who's team actually plays in New Jersey while you douchebags ago.
Why is it called in New England patriots?
This not even a Boston team.
That's how dumb New Yorkers are.
They don't realize that Massachusetts is in New England.
It's a region of the northeast.
All right,
for all you fucks who don't know your history.
The Boston Patriots started out,
they played it Nickerson field.
Nobody showed up because nobody knew who the fuck they were.
It was considered an inferior league.
They were going bankrupt in an a desperate attempt to try to rope in more
fucking fans.
They switched to New England patriots.
Something that I have never liked.
I still think that they should be called the Boston patriots.
All that fucking Patriot tea party horse,
shit all happened at Boston.
They should be called the Boston patriots,
but they're not.
So that's why.
But Boston is a new England.
You Dumb New York or Fox and you guys got a lot of nerve considering the New
York jets and the New York giants play in New Jersey and share a fucking
stadium.
It's why don't you guys stand the fuck down.
All right.
See,
that's what always happens.
I always make good points about football and then my hatred of New York just
comes up in a minute.
You'll love it.
Every God to,
you know,
something.
I actually don't even hate the giants.
I actually liked the giants.
MMM,
no,
no.
I liked the uniforms.
I like the old helmet that they went back to.
I,
I liked them.
I liked their style of play.
That smash mouth,
Defensive Shit.
I know that they kind of suck so far.
But uh,
I a conference,
a good coach.
Maybe you can turn it around.
I don't know.
I don't
know what,
but uh,
there's something about the jets.
I just,
there,
you know what it is.
Their fans are desperate and there's just something,
when you smell desperation,
you just want to see failure,
you know?
Okay.
They just stopped it about that silly little fireman on top of his boyfriend
shoulders and they're 1920s cheer,
j e t s jets,
jets,
and they,
and they think that that cheer is awesome.
That's what kills me the same way it kills me when red sox fans sink sweet
Caroline and they think it's awesome to be going.
Bob,
Bob on with your fucking chicks head on your shoulder.
I swear to God if I could,
if I became the next Hitler,
but going big on this one.
Okay.
The people that I would target would be red sox fans.
Anybody who sings pop up,
I'm in the seventh inning of a red sox game and anyone who puts a fireman on
this shoulder and goes,
j e t as jets,
jets,
jets.
That's it.
You're out.
You're fucking out.
You're done.
Yeah.
All right.
You're not part of my master plan.
How g she is.
How fucked up was that?
Well go fuck yourself.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all the,
uh,
police come out to my shows.
I've got a brand new hour and,
um,
I,
I think I have a new group.
I think I have a new,
a fun joke about a goat.
I'm hoping it killed in Nashville,
but God knows those peak.
God knows the people down there.
Come on,
man.
Who's kidding?
Who,
how does it goat joke?
Not Kill and fucking Tennessee.
All right.
The real test.
It's not even gonna be in Albany,
I think will be in Buffalo,
Albany.
I don't know.
There's a lot of farm land around there.
Do you know that's the highway.
I hate the most,
the 87 north,
just because for so much of my career I drove up there either a bus or a rental
car,
just go into some fucking nightmare of a gig.
So I just always associated with that.
I have talked too long.
I have overstayed my welcome.
God bless all.
Yeah,
I'll see you next week.